how does it feel well for you to be back
here in South Africa folks seemed in
your element yes yes it was great I'm
just starting and younger was was
amazing I mean I think everyone across
the world now has probably heard about
what's been happening more recently that
kind of stuff happens all the time every
year but it really peaked in the last in
the last month or so we've done our best
to try and keep track of what's been
going on but you know South Africa was
was always going to be all this Africa
tour was always going to be fantastic
we've been looking forward to coming to
visit Cape Town her first visit I love
this place and again meeting the people
the energy the fun again the positive
the positivity the optimism and the hope
in the face of such incredible adversity
there are there are young people and
older people men and women trying to
change what effectively has become the
norm reaching out to young people is
obviously so important for you both and
but what do you think is the most
pressing global issue when it comes to
dealing with the stigma around mental
health which still continues in so many
places today just getting people to talk
talk about it and talk to each other
right and you see that matter where you
are in the world you're in a small
community or a Township if you're in a
big city it's that everyone is dealing
with a different version of the same
thing globally I think there's a bit of
a consciousness crisis and so the fact
that we are able to be here together and
see on the ground so much good work
that's being done just because people
are willing to talk to each other about
it and someone's willing to listen is
huge and that can apply to being here
certainly can apply to being in London
LA it doesn't matter where you are we're
all sort of trying to power through and
find some optimism I think most of the
stigma around mental illness right we
need to separate the two this is more
about consciousness as mental health
which is every single one of us and then
mental illness which could be every
single one of us but I think they need
to be they need to be separated because
the mental health element touches on so
much of what we're exposed to these
experiences that these kids and every
single one of us has been through
everyone has experienced trauma or
likely experienced trauma some
during our lives we need to try and not
eradicate it but to learn from previous
generations so that we don't so that
it's not a perpetual cycle and I think
what's amazing here is just in a day and
the same conversations keep happening
with with all sorts of different people
so they've been through it and we can
learn so much from them